many pools and clubs on the las vegas
strip are back open
they were closed for nearly a year
because of the coven 19 pandemic
madison kimbrough joins us live from the
strip tonight after speaking with
visitors about the return
of these entertainment options madison
what did they tell you
yes it was mixed reaction on the strip
tonight many people we spoke to were
from out of town visiting for the
weekend
many excited for vegas to get back to
that lifestyle that it's known for
others thinking it's too soon if you
feel like you can't go outside and you
feel you're going to get sick then just
stay in the house
travelers from all over the world come
to vegas to experience the nightlife and
swanky pool access
we offer and now with our situation
improving more places are opening up
once again while crowded dance floors
and packed venues are still not allowed
many nightclubs and pool lounges have
changed the way they operate
and with capacity limits set to reach 50
percent by next week
more and more people are ready to dive
back in i would partake in the pools i
don't think i would partake in the clubs
i guess as long as you have your
vaccine vaccination it'd be okay if not
then you have to be very careful
we both had covet already we think it's
kind of crazy we have to stand outside
right now and wear these things
especially in a pool you know pool party
or something like that
omnia at caesars palace just reopened
excess at encore
and the foundation room at mandalay bay
have also reopened too
as for pool venues the encore beach club
opened this past friday
along with marquis at the cosmopolitan
and wet republic at mgm grand
while there are those that are ready
there are still many that believe
reopening now
is still too soon as far as us walking
around i think that's fine
getting to you know the fresh air but
other than that no i don't think we
should be getting in the pool
and going to night clubs together that's
too close
and popular las vegas mgm resort
properties such as mandalay bay
the mirage and also park mgm have now
fully
reopened reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now